bonjour à tous bienvenue bienvenue à
chacune et chacun d'entre vous vous êtes
venus de toutes les régions de france
paca nord pas de calais picardie
languedoc-roussillon midi-pyrénées
aquitaine limousin poitou-charentes
rhône-alpes auvergne pays de la loire
normandie alsace lorraine champagne
ardenne bourgogne franche comté centre
val de loire ile-de-france et bretagne
sans oublier l'outre-mer et les français
de l'étranger merci d'être ici présents
vous êtes les représentants les
républicains de vos territoires
vous êtes membre de droit où vous avez
été élu par les adhérents
vous êtes délégué de circonscription
conseiller national trésorier
responsable des jeunes hommes femmes
indépendants salariés retraités
étudiants élus locaux et parlementaires
choisi pour la première fois ou réélus
par vos pairs vous êtes les visages des
républicains vous êtes le parlement des
républicains et au nom de l'équipe
dirigeante
je tiens à vous féliciter très
chaleureusement d'avoir accepté de
prendre des responsabilités au sein de
notre famille politique comme vous l'a
écrit notre président nicolas sarkozy au
plus près de nos adhérents et de nos
concitoyens votre rôle est désormais
d'organiser et d'animer la vie de votre
circonscription de votre ferr fédération
d'en faire un lieu des changes et de
débats et j'ajouterais d'incarner une
offre politique qui donne envie aux plus
grands nombres de s'engager bien sûr à
nos côtés ça va sans dire mais ça va
mieux en le disant
votre première mission si vous
l'acceptez sera d'assurer le service
après vente de ce conseil national qui
va se dérouler sur deux jours
un conseil national frappée sous le
sceau de la démocratie directe
et de la transparence où la parole est
libre
contrairement à d'autres formations
politiques qui se réunissent à huis clos
nous n'avons rien à cacher de nos débats
car les questions que nous nous posons
les français se les posent
car le projet d'alternance que nous
construisons ensemble
les français veulent y prendre leur part
alors oui nous prenons un risque à
débattre ouvertement en présence des
caméras et des micros et je salue les
journalistes nombreux ce matin avec nous
alors non nous ne serons pas d'accord
sur tout mais oui nous serons nous
écouter nous respecter et répondre à des
questions de fond qui sommes nous
quelles sont nos valeurs partagées
que voulons nous quel est le projet que
nous proposons aux français avec qui
voulons nous gouverner autrement dit qui
sont nos partenaires naturels naturel et
si possible loyaux notre famille
politique est aujourd'hui réunies nous
sommes tous membres des républicains
dans nos communes dans les départements
dans nos régions nous incarnons un
espoir
cet espoir qu'ils procurent aux êtres
humains le sentiment d'avoir un but et
leur donne l'énergie d'aller de l'avant
sur ce et avant d'inviter nos deux
candidats à la présidence du conseil
national à s'exprimer un point sur le
déroulé de la matinée expression dans
l'ordre et pour cinq minutes chacun
d'eux michèle alliot marie puis de luc
chatel puis vote pour la présidence du
conseil national le vote avec bulletins
et urnes est ouvert jusqu'à 12 heures
pendant le vote s'exprimeront à la
tribune roger karoutchi qui reviendra
sur les élections départementales et
régionales avec de si belles victoires
dont nous nous sommes tous réjouit eric
ciotti
qui évoquera la vie des fédérations le
résultat des élections internes qui font
de notre famille politique
un vrai parti démocratique daniel
fasquelle nos très chers trésorier qui
fera le point sur nos finances et je
crois que ça va mieux
eric woerth notre secrétaire général en
charge du projet qui dirige une belle
équipe de délégués généraux de
secrétaires nationaux en terme en charge
de thématiques précises un énorme
travail merci eric avant d'ouvrir à
proprement parler le débat avec vous
dans la salle notre président nicolas
sarkozy vous expliquera ce qu'il attend
de nous tous et vous indiquera quelques
points de méthode
vos prises de paroles seront rythmées
par séquence d'environ 20 minutes est
ponctuée d'interventions et de réponse
des membres de l'équipe dirigeante
ici présentes à la tribune avant le
déjeuner vous aurez à connaître le nom
du nouveau président ou la nouvelle
présidente du conseil national à qui je
cèderai volontiers ma place pour animer
cette riche journée
je n'ai fait ce matin qu' assurer
l'intérim
et à cet instant d'ouverture du conseil
national en votre nom
je veux permet de rendre un hommage
appuyé à celui qui a exercé cette
mission de président du conseil national
avec beaucoup de rigueur et tellement
d'humour
pendant des années il nous rejoindra je
veux parler de jean pierre raffarin
bonne journée à tous et au travail les
républicains